depuis tout à l'heure je vais faire un
truc d'enfantement c'était une bêtise
quoi vraiment ca mais je crève d'envié
nos médias dans le débat du tout mais
c'est vrai s'arrêter là oui non regardez
non parce qu'il faut qu'on le rencontre
s'il va être noir oui mais justement je
sens que ça va vous mettre un tout petit
peu dans la merde et chez un tout petit
peu aurait dû voir le
dollar s'il vous plaît
j'appelle la police
vous voyez il fait chaud mais il sent le
brûlé ce qui est étrange parce que les
qu'est ce que c'est que cette matière
j'ai jamais su du clan et en cuivre et
guy et une dalle il faut parler couvre
le tout voilà ces critiques c'est made
in france et qu'il faut à peu près 15
heures pour fabriquer une statuette pour
la petite histoire voilà juste le temps
de la cérémonie
terminée
on va se rassembler on va même